hey everyone my name is John Roca for
Collider I'm here with the outlaw Josie
Wales my man Clint Eastwood and palmach
Hauser I'm talk to me my man you got to
work with the great Clint Eastwood lead
role in this care in this film Richard
Jewell what was this like for you it was
an honor for all the obvious reasons
because of his filmography and his
reputation and and I grew up watching a
lot of his films and in the line of fire
I forgot to mention that's one of those
movies in my childhood was always on TV
yeah but I probably saw it four or five
six times and it was fun watching you
you know you know he's good when he can
be on the phone with the villain and
that's as visceral as them facing off
you know it was it was a joy to just get
to meet him
and I had hoped that we would gel
creatively you never know
right right right kind of going blindly
but he knows how to work with actors cuz
he is one yeah well you're you're
fantastic in this film Paul and I
Clinton you get such a great performance
out of him tell me what inspired you to
tell this story at this time in your
life and at this time in our country's
history because I'm over read about the
mule you said you read the article yeah
let's do that but this is a deeper
exploration of this character and what
happened to him well I've been chasing
this film for somewhere of three four or
five years now and it's different
circumstances came up that I couldn't
get the property era there was with
Studios that weren't weren't quite keen
on it but I always was keen on the story
and that's great I thought that the
script was good and I thought I could
had potential to be a really important
story and talking about a very tragic
situation yeah you know the ruining of a
man's life and probably the shortening
of his life due to us
I've read out-of-control
bat facets right press maybe jumping too
soon
jumping too hard and the agencies
everybody needing a quick conclusion to
the thing just to protect the the event
that was gonna be there yeah you know I
remember living through this
I remember reading all the papers about
it all happened in the transition was oh
my god is it the security guard now oh
my god it was crazy and you bring all
that out in the film but you know as I'm
looking through your filmography you
seem to always make you seem to be drawn
to these characters that are fighting
against the system or fighting the
uphill battle the little guy against the
big guy and I wonder if that has always
been with you since in your career as
well as an actor because I remember that
you were playing are you draw Gunsmoke
and you weren't getting a shot at lead
characters you had to go to Italy to
become a lead so maybe you connect to
these characters having to fight against
the system and to be proved to prove
themselves yeah you know it was I think
I gravitated towards those kind of those
kind of roles I'm sorry that's all right
it's the same CBS did that for a lot of
years six years and over that time you
kind of you deal with all kinds of stuff
you deal with good scripts bad scripts
mediocre and and you're passing out
products and then the idea of going to
Italy and doing a thing which they're
using the plotline in another movie but
it is I actually did that and it was it
was good this good for me
good for me to work with other people
other societies and
for obstacles and not obstacles but just
different look at things and you know as
it's eventually you stack up enough
stuff in your head and you try to
utilize some of it certainly comes
through in the films that you're making
that's for damn sure and I noticed that
again with another great world like
Richard Jewell well had you been
familiar with the story before you took
it on and if you what surprised you the
most as you were doing your research for
playing Richard yeah I was not familiar
because I was 9 and a half when the
event took place but um but I knew of
the story because of the project I knew
that Hollywood was making a biopic of
Richard Jewell and and the people
involved were really talented and so I
was a scientist paying the film and then
when I got the part I did some research
and then kind of just realized that
there was an accumulation of
circumstantial evidence that to the
general public was translated as
evidence yeah not circumstantial it was
evidence to them in the minds of most
viewers so the imbalance of truth there
was deeply disheartening and and and you
know my heart goes out to Richard but I
do feel we I feel we're giving some form
of a culmination in conclusion with this
film
odhh agree with you Oh - I got emotional
couple times watching the movie seeing
that struggle that he was going through
and connecting
I mean grabbing Ben the military myself
connecting with a guy who's oh thank you
wanting to you know wanted to be part of
an organization wanting so bad to be
taken seriously and then having that
thrown back in his face when he's done
something really good what a terrible
turn of events that was for him so I
think you capture it both in your
direction Clinton and your acting the
journey that this guy went through that
is so human and heartbreaking you know
absolutely I want to ask you something
are you ever gonna try to comedy I mean
you did comedies way back in the 70s
Bronco Billy and stuff what do you want
to do I love I love comedies you know
sometimes a good drama is that is the
basis
are you know you know of conflict you
know our conflict is this basis of drama
or whatever but then there's those
stories of conflict whether it's broad
conflict like a action film or whether
it's a hitter is is always interesting
to delve in and I just thought this one
day you know this is real screwing over
this guy go and people jump to
conclusions and I just hope that they
people would think more deeply before
anyway it's just a it's just fun to do
them I would love to do comedies but
yeah I can't but you got to go before
what you puts there it's like somebody's
always saying would you ever like to do
a Western again I said well I don't know
unforgiven seemed like a good one to end
on yeah and then I thought that would
have if somebody write a good one
that equals of that I would say yes but
at the same token I don't search for any
particular type of write of project well
he's a funny guy this Paul Walter Houser
guy so maybe he should write something
yeah he could say maybe we can merge him
and we'll find a true story that has
some drama and it's also funny I think I
think you know there's some films like
changeling where you're not gonna really
be laughing ever probably but um but but
I think this films similar to Gran
Torino there's some some elements of
comedy or comedic moments that
absolutely bring levity amidst the it's
the heaviness absolutely one last
question for you Clint I'd be in trouble
if I don't ask for this I play the
outlaw in where I live and where I work
at Collider I miss my nickname for hims
because of your my influence or your
influence on me but I need to ask you
this Unforgiven there are rumors that
there is a director's cut or a longer
cut out there and not to get into a
Snider cut situation but I want to ask
you
is there a director's cut somewhere
hidden in your archives that you'd like
to release some now the director's cut
was with it what you saw in the movie
that's it straight from the bombs that's
right that's right well that's gonna ask
thank you so much Klan thank you so much
Paul this is this is John wrote for
Collider go see Richard Jewell this one
is fantastic